on va passer les dunes aux deux jours et
sont plus en plus nombreux à parler du
grand remplacement ce phénomène qui fait
très peur à l'extrême droite et qui
serait selon eux et le remplacement du
peuple français de souche par
l'immigration aujourd'hui c'est le
magazine causeur qui crée la polémique
et fait énormément parler avec sa
nouvelle lune souriez vous êtes grand
remplacer regarder ça et on va en parler
juste après avec elisabeth lévy la
fondatrice du magazine et il y aura
louis brouillard qui va arriver aussi
qu'ils vénèrent comme personne te dire
ce que vous en pensez ça ça a été la
panique du mois enfin une des polémiques
du
peuple français qui souffrent de cette
folle politique d'immigration qui se
traduit chaque jour un peu plus par une
immigration non plus de peuplement mais
de remplacement et dans certaines villes
voire de région de grand remplacement le
grand remplacement et la créolisation
pour moi c'est d'autres sont des termes
synonymes simplement les premiers disent
c'est une catastrophe et les seconds is
c'est magnifique mais c'est la même
chose oui un basculement démographique
qui pourrait faire craindre que la
france ne change de visage dans quelques
années et c'est déjà en train d'arriver
si la france se met à devenir la patrie
de tout le monde alors elle n'est plus
la patrie de personnes alors regardez là
une de causeur voilà regarder souriez
vous êtes grand remplace alors ça fait
énormément parler merci elizabeth loewy
d'être avec nous vous avez fait cette
une pourquoi on a fait cet pour engager
à des questions pour alerter sur un
phénomène si vous devez alors moi je
suis tout à fait frapper par le festival
de gros mots du dimanche vous savez à
mailhac ignoble un pam et ça me fait
penser à cette phrase de nietzsche qui
dit nullement autant qu'un homme indigné
parce que je ne vois pas beaucoup
d'arguments alors je peux vous expliquer
pourquoi on l'a fait si vous voulez je
dis ça va faire un buzz comme on s'est
dit que ça allait déclencher le braille
aux lettres non un peu l'habitude du
brio m en général concept des clauses le
braille omettre on pense c'est vrai
qu'on a frappé juste et qu'on est tombé
sur un point sensible mais moi je vois
bien l'expliquer parce que évidemment la
plupart des gens sérieux ne se sont pas
donné la peine de lire les articles sont
illustrés par cette une mais c'est la
une qui est le plus dur si oui mais
enfin c'est quand même vraiment béton
vous savez que c'est par le journal
d'image seulement c'est pas une bande
dessinée causeur non mais il nous est en
faisant cette rue nous savions que ça
allait énormément de l'euro les accès tu
es voulait alerter sur le phénomène
ok je suis déçu parce que causeur c'est
un magazine qui se veut être très cash
très direct et en fait j'ai lu justement
les trente pages c'est un énorme dossier
vous faites des cartes des statistiques
des interviews etc bref vous tourner
autour du pot pour démontrer une chose
pardon je vais être réducteur mais vous
dites en gros il ya trop d'étrangers en
france qu'il ya trop de noirs ya trop
d'arabes ces gens là se reproduise tron
et qu'ils n'aiment pas la france si vous
avez lieu comme ça par dollars oui j'ai
lu entièrement et quand vous mettez je
vais juste vous dire la première photo
de l'article c'est une photo d'un
quartier de parilly crois que ces
châteaux d'eau et vous montrer en gros
qui a que des noirs c'est ça que vous
voulez démontrer autre kayliah bonjour
mon peuple exclus des blocs en gros vous
n'avez pas le cran d'assumer que je
voulais juste dire qu'il ya trop
d'étrangers en france qu'il ait jamais
joué merci je vous remercie de me lier 2
2 me de vous faire mon interprète mais
je vais quand même le faire tout seul
premièrement d'accord vous savez il ya
une pub qui dit gouvernementale on peut
débattre de tout sauf des chiffres alors
je pense qu'en fait ces faucons à droite
débattent d'egypte mais en l'occurrence
cela bien du gouvernement d'accord et
nous montre quoi que une part croissante
des naissances d'enfants dans ce pays
ont un ou deux parents d'origine
étrangère extra européenne et de
cultures étrangères alors vous allez
vous dire on s'en fout que les enfants
soir noir blanc jaune ou bleu on s'en
fout c'est sûr que s'ils voulaient le
problème n'est pas que notre société
soit multi ethnique c'est qu'elle soit
multiculturelle c'est à dire que si tous
ces enfants étaient élevés comme des
français d'amour de coeur de valeur et
de mars je m'en foutrais mais
complètement le problème c'est que ça
n'est pas le cas et que dans ces
quartiers je vais vous éviter la tarte à
la crème des femmes je vous ai donné
deux autres exemples ces volets pourquoi
je dis que culturellement ça pose un
problème
une première c'est que nous vivons dans
une culture occidentale française où
l'individu s'émancipe de sa communauté
ce qui se passe dans un certain nombre
de cultures qu'elle soit d'ailleurs ou
pas islamique mais qui sont maghrébine
subsaharienne et d'autres c'est que la
communauté reprend ses droits sur
l'individu et je vous donne un autre
exemple en france on a le droit de se
moquer des croyances des autres et de
ses propres croyances on a le droit de
dire merde à dieu voilà c'est comme ça
et bien il y a des quartiers de ce pays
où on n'aurait pas le droit de se
baladée avec des caricatures
et
à des amalgames vous sous-entendez tous
les étrangers l'aiment pas là c'est pas
bien de faire ça évidemment les
individus il ya des individus qui
échappent mais ce que vous voulez en
venir avec ça c'est quoi le message est
bien c'est que si nous nassim ils l'ont
pas il y aura demain un pays qui ne sera
plus la france ce sera peut-être
formidable mais ce ne sera plus ce pays
où je peux me balader en minijupe
partout ce ne sera plus ce pays où je
peux dire merde au dieu des autres parce
qu'il ya des gens qui quand on paie cela
je vous adresse posent des bombes tuent
c'est terrible ça
générait pas choqué si tu m'a choqué je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi fait tonner
ouais parce que c'est leur faire trop
d'honneur c'est leur faire trop
d'honneur d'être choqués parce qu'ils
ont cherché que ça quand on lit les
pages à l'intérieur tous les chiffres
sont faux madame les victimes habitaient
chez vous allez dire ça vaut expliqué j
il faut expliquer que causeur est en
grande difficulté et c'est votre ultime
provocation s'est passé en or comme
argument mais tiré non non mais laissez
moi l'argument si vous avez des
arguments l'ina vous parler mais c'est
un argument qui n'a pas l'air est en
grande difficulté vous parler hockey
écoutez vous parlez de l'immigration de
rang parliez de l'immigration répéter
vous me reposez moi parler de votre logo
pas sûr désert venant nous donner
l'argent j'essaye d'aller si c'est bon
les l'immigration subsaharienne dont
vous parlez l'immigration du sud ces 5 %
de la population français vous n'avez
pas lu les cibles depuis des décennies
c'est l'insee qui le dit ça n'évolue
la peur que vous mais ça n'a rien à voir
sur la rue jacques bigot carrie ça n'a
rien à voir vous véhiculez des images et
les chiffres anglais déchire bien
mentalement c'est 5% ça ne bouge pas
depuis des décennies pardonnez moi ce
que vous dites comme théorie de la peur
dans les grands classements et passifs
les jeux pc les vôtres qui s'en fait
oui bonne à dire le juge précise et les
chiffres ne viennent pas de moi igal
d'un organisme qui s'appelle france
stratégique est un organisme public et
que ces chiffres avancés bon je ne parle
pas ces chiffres parlent tout simplement
d'origine mais que matt une dame quand
une dame vous dis qu'il n'ya pas de
blancs dans la tasse de mon fils quand
on me parle de minorités visibles donc
voit le parlement mais déjà première
chose quand vous dites que vous parlez
de culture je ne vous crois pas ah ben
si jamais la culture vous auriez pas mis
des bébés vous auriez pas mis les
personnes de couleur est probable et
l'âme c'est surtout ce qui me choque
c'est le terme grand remplacement il
faut expliquer ce que c'est curieusement
ces personnes qui pensent que
volontairement ou involontairement
l'immigration va effacer remplacer une
ethnie blanche ou non si c'est sa propre
nourriture se seraient remplacés par des
personnes d'origine maghrébine des
personnes noires des liens asiatiques
quand on parle du grand remplacement on
admis l'existence de races et c'est pour
ça que le terme grand remplaçants et les
personnes qui en parle elles sont
racistes et enfin il ya une deuxième
chose vous parler de culture vous parler
d'intégration mais dans vos papiers vous
n'en parlez pas amarré avec ces écoles
où sont ses enfants dit normalement je
voudrais
d'assimilation français c'est moi si
vous vous inclinez jamais de sa valeur
défensive être vous allez rien qu'en
fait quand vous parlez des quartiers moi
j'aimerais bien avoir la chance de
pouvoir parler de ça à longueur de
journée mais quand je me promène dans la
rue quand je discute avec les gens il me
parle pas de la couleur de peau leur
voisin il parle des 10 millions de
pauvres qui avant ce pays un bandeau
revient pas les mêmes en fait le truc
c'est que vous êtes obsédés par la race
parce que c'est tout ce que vous allez
on la voit pas ce que vous connaissez
rien à la vie des personnes à ce
qu'avançait alors saveurs de kabore nous
ne parlons pas nous ne parlons pas de
raft à aucun moment ce mot n'est pas
écrit nous parlons d'après les cartes de
francs stratégie donc qui s est
intéressé à la nationalité des parents
des enfants nous parlons donc d'origine
exactement puisque plus parler pardon je
finis quand vous parlez de diversité
vous parlez d'origine quand vous parlez
quand une dame à montpellier bien
s'inquiéter qu'il n'y ait pas assez de
blond dans la classe de son fils elle
par une bo exil longue et je m'inquiète
n'ont pas de cette origine ou de la
couleur de peau je m'inquiète parce que
alors à la fois à cause du nombre et
parce que nous n'exigeons rien ça avec
cette origine 20 une affirmation
identitaire culturelle qui fait que dans
un certain nombre de quartiers et qui ne
sont plus seulement les banlieue
parisienne ou lyonnaise mais qui sont
aussi orléans limoges et cetera ce n'est
plus la culture ce n'est plus le ce ne
sont plus les moeurs françaises qui
prévalent dans la cité dans les
relations entre les gens et je m'en
inquiète parce que cela veut dire quoi
que à terme liasses qu'elisabeth
badinter avait happé un changement de
peuples ça n'est pas la couleur de la
peau qui fait qu'il ya un changement du
peuple c'est encore une fois si tous ces
gens étaient des français de coeur de
balleure 6 été élevée comme cela cela ne
me gênerait pas mais quand vous vous
appelez quand vous appelez quelqu'un
d'autre mon frère où mon cousin
simplement parce qu'elles aiment la même
couleur de peau que vous faire quand
vous n'appartenez pas exactement à
l'assemblée nationale je vous crois pas
parce que là vous êtes comme une
quadrette et moi j'ai une question à
vous poser bon c'est une étude
démographique au départ pourquoi vous
l'avez détourné pour faire du marketing
de l'horreur c'est du racisme c'est
dangereux c'est clivant qu'est-ce qu'on
reconnaît aujourd'hui d'ailleurs vous
mentez à l'intérieur genia - il ya moins
d'enfants aujourd'hui de deux parents
d'immigrés qu'en 1990 on est passé de 27
à 24 ports et un ep c'est la preuve de
ce que vous dites et du monde et du
racing c'est donc moi ma question non ma
question
on se fait envahir ces de
l'envahissement ce que vous dites c'est
de l'embellissement bon est ce que je
peux répondre à ce qu'on peut répondre à
une question aussi malhonnête et
pardonnez-moi pas très futés parce que
marketing de l'horreur c'est encore nul
ne montrent aucun sommes indignés par
ces votants très actif qui nous
connaissent aujourd'hui connaissez
maintenant vous avez de la chance moi je
me connais pas déjà donc
essayé d'argumenter
je suis prête à vous n'avez pas répondu
depuis tout à l'heure je vous parle de
quelques unes étudier vos mardi qu il
avait détourné répondez moi même écouter
vous n'avez pas ce que c'est gratuit et
qui doit même servi de 60 voilà pourquoi
j'ai détourné ces caniveaux je suis
désolé c'est clément il en fait
il faut échanger mais dignement
vous savez ce que c'était grand place
dans les mosquées calais il a revendiqué
du lourd en remplacement de m mais c'est
vrai j'ai refermé au cours
d'un combat s'impose pour une question
quel moment on parle de ceux de cette
une ou pas et lui fait une culturel
excusez moi ou pour les détenus avec un
blanc un noir un asiatique voilà déjà
rien que ça dans la symbolique c'est pas
bon vous souffler sur les braises de de
la haine c'est le fonds de commerce mais
apte à défendre que baisse de l'extase
moi de vous parler après deux cultures
et après vous parler de religion et vous
faites une [ __ ] sionisation avec un
petit taquet sur l'islam c'est pas bon
tout ça pas en ce moment je vous le dis
il ya sûrement une tête et une à deux
secondes fini il y avait une petite
étude sympathique des débats grrrr
démographique mais au final au final moi
je vous le dis en ce moment avec tout ce
qui se passe merci moi il manque un mois
avec tout ce qui se passe se trouve ça
pas dangereux brel en dangereux effectif
et je finis je finis et vous avec le
québec avec la petite dose de sa prime
d'intégration voilà donc c'est le
fourneau maire doit pas vous rêvez je
vous en prie allez je crois pour aller
très vite que ce qui est dangereux et ce
qui alimente la haine c'est le déni
c'est de dire aux gens vous ne vivez pas
ce que vous vivez vous ne voyez pas ce
que vous voyez quand vous allez dans
certains quartiers où à l'évidence ce ne
sont plus les moeurs françaises la
culture française la liberté français la
liberté des femmes qui prévalent et bien
les gens le voient encore une fois je le
répète nous ne parlons pas de race nous
parlons des origines à partir de cette
étude parce que avec les au régime
d'islamabad
la souris à vous êtes un grand repas on
savait que la vue voilée allez faire à
la lumière ce scandale
dit rien on
voudrait un nom parce que c'est vrai
qu'à leur âge que moi je suis pas choqué
par cette union parce que c'est le fond
de commerce de causeur c'est très bien
mais oui c'est l'opposition et ses
environs sont pleins mais
j'aimerais juste posé la question à ce
qu'on a un fond de commerce bien sûr
évidemment qu'on peut s'amener sur une
une de charlie hebdo etc etc mais j'ai
lu vos claviers ces lieux sauf études
effectivement ça part d'une enquête
démographique etc mais au fait qu'est ce
qui vous dérange dans le
pluriculturalisme ça c'est une question
intéressante et bien je crois que le
multiculturalisme qui n'est pas laid qui
n'est pas si vous voulez la présence de
plusieurs cultures mais la présence à
égalité de plusieurs fermetures sur un
même sol eh bien je crois que c'est le
germe de la guerre je crois que l'épée
le but d'abord ça ne marche pas même
dans les pays où il est de tradition
mais en france il faut qu'il y ait une
culture de référence et moi par exemple
les enquêtes ne sont absolument pas
gaulois mais je suis immensément
reconnaissante à ce pays qui me prête
ses ancêtres si vous voulez adopter
immigrés changé c'est aussi changer un
peu de généalogie vous pouvez tout à
fait garder votre attachement à votre
culture d'origine mais vous devez
adhérer aux moeurs françaises or
aujourd'hui si on les met toute égalité
si vous voulez vous voyez bien qu'il n'y
a plus nécessité de s'adapter alors on
ne peut plus demander aux gens s'ils
voulaient de dire on ne peut plus dire
aux gens ben oui être français ça
suppose par exemple que chez nous on a
le droit de faire des caricatures et
vous n'allez pas protester contre ce
plan
s'élèvent à l'ailé parce qu'il nous
reste les luttes mathy bah ouais magie
cette ouverture on dirait une propagande
un peu des du siècle dernier mois je me
rappelle que j'ai étudié ça quand je dis
aux gens c'est
en voyant un peu d'aidé déjà de ce genre
de couverture c'est un peu de la
propagande et je comprends pas le but a
pas attiser la haine enfin je veux dire
quand on voit ces images sur twitter
voir conclu attention le mien et on lit
pas forcément l'article à l'intérieur
mais moi tout ce que je vois c'est une
image bien sûr c'est plus la multi que
l'article à l'intérieur pour aller
répéter ouais je conteste pas vos
chiffres parce que je suis pas
démographe et ses palmes et voilà mais
en revanche ce que vous la voyez pas que
vous leur faites dire voilà j'espère on
est là pour parler de la husqvarna
christiane inférieur et voilà je magie
va justement ce que vous leur faites
dire me pose souci parce que vous avez
évidemment comme vous êtes cultivez vous
savez exactement ce que vous dites il
avait de lévis le grand remplacement
vous savez très bien que c'est the one
look à lui que c'est une tasse de renaud
camus qu'elle est considérée comme à la
fois complotistes et qu'elle est battue
en brèche par de nombreux démocrates et
par ailleurs et que par ailleurs sa veux
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il y aurait de
la part des populations de la diversité
un projet politique l'entente de
remplacement de remplacer de façon
volontaire les populations jeunes
européens et oui mais c'est ce que c'est
ce que dit maintenant vous rêviez
poletti qui attend que tout finisse par
me jean
louis mais que dit votre seule commune
avec tous ses
gardes et comme ils sont mignons ces
petits bébés mais tant qu'ils sont bébés
parce qu'après ils vont poser un
problème parce qu'après ils vont vous
remplacer ces sacs elle dit votre essai
enfin elle posa les excuser moi d'abord
moi non je ne le crois pas je crois
quand on fait une à une c'est pour que
les gens essayent de lire oui qui lie à
verrières l'accroché le moment voulu
accrocher le lecteur à la croche avec
quelque chose qui peut le vérifier mais
entre nous est choqué ça fait partie
aussi de la vie démocratique de notre
pays nous jeunes anglais s'il peut
dessiner des moustaches de huit lettres
c'est un vocal élevé ces jeunes c'est
ptet pas d'âme si vous voulez c'est très
bien c'est peut-être rigolo c'est ce que
vous venez de faire métaphoriquement
mais ça va pas nous faire avancer le
grand remplacement d'accord c'est une
réalité ça n'est pas un projet c'est le
fait que dans certains quartiers non
certains quartiers qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux qui sont maintenant dans
des petites villes vous vous promenez
vous n'êtes plus en france ça veut pas
dire que c'est mal ça veut pas dire ça
veut dire que vous avez
géré si on a un grand coach choqué par
l'incident oui un peu peuvent pour son
nom à swiss et la politique de causeur
depuis le premier numéro sur le web et
d'un décodeur
on débat et on ne connait pas posé
choqué par la lune de charlie voyage en
tout cas près de la gauche à la droite
oui mesdames et messieurs la seule et
ben c'est systématiquement
systématiquement une politique il me
isabelle on nourrit les gens mais pour
l'heure